[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña
asprilla el ex congresista colombiano de
autor del proyecto de reforma policial
en el país a propósito del uso excesivo
de la fuerza que se presenció la semana
pasada con el caso de un ciudadano que
fue brutalmente golpeado hasta
ocasionarle la muerte y que
posteriormente produjo varias protestas
que llevaron a la muerte de al menos 13
personas más muerte a balas gracias
señor asprilla por estar con nosotros en
esta sección aquí en france 24 le
pregunta entonces en qué consiste la
reforma de policía que usted está
proponiendo en colombia
así que nos permite visibilice
colombiano es una reforma que se basa en
tres ejes uno de tipo pedagógico
buscando la implementación obligatoria
una cátedra de desproporción de la
fuerza y de respeto a los derechos
humanos
lo segundo es reformar el sistema
disciplinario creando la figura de un
comisionado de policía que es una
persona civil o una especie defensor del
pueblo que busca que no haya impunidad
el interior de la policía con los
asuntos de control interno de procesos
disciplinarios y lo tercero en
consonancia con la tendencia
o sea mundial una red de procedimientos
para que no se sigan presentando casos
como los que hemos visto en el cual se
prohíbe golpear con el bastón de mando o
tonfa o lillo a los ciudadanos
desarmados en la cabeza se prohíbe la
maniobra de estrangulamiento se regula
el suelte hiciera máximo una descarga
con el objetivo y movilizar a ciudadanos
producto del procedimiento policial
objeto del conocimiento prisiones y
ahora le pregunto entonces por qué no
están regulados estos procedimientos
como el uso el tecer y las maniobras de
estrangulamiento
digamos en colombia hay un problema
político que es real desde producto de
la de la guerra contrasubversiva y de la
guerra contra las drogas
en la cual se creó especie indio ese
ambiente en la policía las fuerzas
políticas tradicionales del país
insisten en llamar a todos los policías
héroes de la patria insisten y ordenan a
los policías tener lo que se llama el
espíritu del cuerpo en el cual un
policía debe callar los actos solos a
los abusos que comentan sus colegas con
el objetivo de guardar la buena imagen
de la institución y además de eso está
la doctrina de la obediencia ciega en el
cual se le ordena al policial siempre
sigue una orden por más inconstitucional
e ilegal que sea este ese es ese
problema ese problema político más el
hecho de la impunidad sistemática que
hay en tanto los procesos disciplinarios
como penales ha llevado a que el
problema del abuso policial se vuelva un
problema estructural en nuestro país
ahora hay otro punto clave para revisar
y es la selección y el proceso además de
formación que reciben quienes van a
integrar la policía nacional colombiana
le pregunto cómo es este proceso
actualmente y qué cambio requiere
digamos el problema del abuso policial
es todo un universo que toca diferentes
aristas es bien sabido que
desafortunadamente en colombia que la
formación es demasiado corta rolando
rondan los 2 años los filtros de entrada
son bastante bajos por decirlo de alguna
manera y eso ha llevado a que de todas
maneras además de eso hay otro problema
y es que la policía se caracteriza por
ser una fuerza un poco clasista una
persona que entra como patrullero de
base tienen poquísimas probabilidades de
llegar a ocupar un alto mando porque
desde el comienzo hay una hay una
división social entre lo que se conoce
como suboficiales o escuela de
suboficiales que son las personas que
están en
capacidad de contar para que no tomando
el patrullero base y todo eso ha
generado digamos que ese clima que de
violación de derechos humanos que
existen la policía hay un patrullero de
base que no es bien formado y que además
digamos siente un trato discriminatorio
respecto a sus superiores desde el
comienzo de su formación y de su
actividad ahora le pregunto entonces
dónde se encuentran principalmente esas
fallas estructurales que permite que se
sigan presentando estos casos de abuso
policial ya nos quedan el 45 segundos de
programa para que sea breve por favor
bueno lo primero es la ausencia de la
policía como un propósito y la policía
está escrita el ministro de defensa
tiene un fuero penal militar que se
caracteriza por la justicia militar se
caracteriza por tasas pesos 90 por
ciento de impunidad y la ausencia un
sistema disciplinario que prevenga que
que prevengan las violaciones más graves
y que cree una cultura
en todos los derechos metros
bueno muchísimas gracias entonces por la
información gracias también por su
tiempo por estar aquí en 5 minutos con
esta sección en nuestro canal france 24
era inti asprilla congresista colombiana
autor del proyecto de reforma policial
en ese país a propósito de lo que ha
ocurrido tras la muerte de el ciudadano
javier ordóñez a manos de la policía
primero fue entonces tratada con una
pistola taser y luego en una calle de
policía hasta aquí cinco minutos con él
gracias por estar con nosotros
[Música]